all right ron desantis
once again is uh putting on a clinic for
us and for other republicans showing how
it's done
um this is like episode 500 of ron
desantis showing how it's done so this
but
this is this is worth really thinking
about and looking at because
um it's very rare that we see this from
republicans in fact we've seen
republicans many times many examples
especially governors and especially in
the last you know several months
uh caving
immediately
um
because of pressure from the left and
especially pressure from corporations
and especially
corporations in their own states
that donate money to them in their
campaigns and whose business you know
you know the powerful corporations in
their own state
most republicans are not especially
republican governors are not able to
withstand that kind of pressure
now ron desantis on the other hand
has disney the most powerful corporation
in his state
and one of the most powerful
corporations in the entire world putting
pressure on him because of this
so-called don't say gay bill
and it's called that because of all the
propaganda and lies being told about it
and he has refused to cave so here he is
uh this is a video from fox
talking again about this and just
showing once again showing republicans
how they should handle these situations
let's listen to some of this
so here's what i can tell you uh in the
state of florida uh we are not going to
allow them to inject
transgenderism into kindergarten
first graders shouldn't have uh woke
gender ideology imposed in their
curriculums and that is what we're
standing for because we're standing for
the kids and we're standing for the
parents uh and i can tell you this
there the chance that i am going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights simply because of
fraudulent media narratives or pressure
from woke corporations the chances of
that are zero
when you have companies that have made a
fortune off being family friendly and
catering to families and young kids you
know they should understand
that parents of young kids do not want
this injected into their kids
kindergarten classroom uh they do not
want their first graders to go and get
told i'm glad you got to that that's
another good point about disney that is
not appropriate right for those of you
so there's there's ron desantis that's
something another good point about
disney is that they are
they produce content for children and
now they have come out so strongly in
favor of sexually grooming children
and so if you let your children
um consume content from disney it might
be something worth thinking about in the
future of course we should have been
thinking about it before because disney
has been crazy leftist for a long time
um
but that's that's ron santos i mean he's
i i'll keep on saying it until it until
it manifests and becomes reality but
he's he's got to be the guy i mean we're
it's crazy
to consider
anybody else at this point there's just
there's just nobody else
who's on his level
um and that
of course includes trump ron desantis
what you saw there that's that's he's
got all of the the upside of trump and
none of the downside
the only thing that trump has that
sanders doesn't have is all the name
recognition of course trump is one of
the most famous people in the world and
he was even before he ran for president
so desantis doesn't have that to that
extent
but if he's the guy and and he's the
republican nominee then he's going to
get a lot of
name
recognition that's that's that's a
problem you can solve but when it comes
to qualities as a politician it comes to
that like what he brings to the table in
terms of his skill
um he's got anything trump has and um
and there's a lot of downside that trump
has that he doesn't have
and he's also able to
which i think is really important
you know using the bully pulpit
as they say
being able to talk about these issues
in um you know you don't have to be
shakespeare
and ron desantis is and he comes off
like a basically a normal guy
and that's that's good actually
but he's able to talk about these issues
in a in a coherent way
like he can focus
you get the sense that you could sit
down from across the table from ron to
santos and talk about an issue
um for 30 minutes
and he could stay on topic and and talk
about it and offer some insight
you know whereas with trump it's it's
all over the place he's he's not able to
stay on message at all about anything
and um you just don't you don't get the
sense that he quite
is quite as engaged with these issues or
cares about them
um the same way that you do with ron
desantis
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated